human beings have forever been concerned
with the ways in which they can mediate
the contents of consciousness David
Lanson called it increased stewardship
of internal life and we've been told by
wise men throughout the ages that what
is within becomes without but in turn
what is without becomes within to echo
Marshall McLuhan we build the tools and
the tools build us Steven Johnson our
thoughts shape our spaces but our spaces
return the favor and so again a key idea
here is that if we're dealing with the
technical material of subjectivity
itself in theory or the way to mediate
our inferiority of side from mindful
self inquiry and meditation is through
harnessing the power of built
environments right power of architecture
if you want to shape Minds shape spaces
in which those minds dwell and so we're
here in Tulum a community of intention
where resorts like nomadic have taken it
upon themselves to shape spaces that
inform Minds the shapes spaces the
engineer ways being ways of seeing
thinking for the first time in history
the mind subjectivity consciousness has
become an engineering project one
impregnated with intentionality
we have turned ourselves into the
ultimate canvas to be hacked the
ultimate canvas to be upgraded to be
redefined to move deeper into this
mystery of stealth capital s people call
it a revolution in consciousness people
call it a revolution in thinking but
it's really a revolution in architecting
mind by architecting space building and
knitting together communities thought by
laying down sticks and bricks together
to create spaces that inform those very
communities of mine
we're talking about turning our mind
inside out essentially and making it
into this hoodie of clay that we can
mold into beautifu capes and so it's
something I think about a lot because
I'm interested in how consciousness can
be taken to the very next level and so
witnessing spaces in places where this
is already being put into practice is
endlessly inspiring again we write
interior life that's the engineering
project that's what we're aiming to hack
that's what it's all about
[Music]